[Music]
just feel like family should be together
at now Nashville's spring finale was
gut-wrenching to say the least
as we saw what life looks like without
Rayna James this man just lost the love
of his life how's he supposed to act we
need to be there for fans also got to
see Maddie's quick rise to fame after
her emotional tribute performance at the
CMT Awards she struggles with gaining
success so soon after her mother's death
promise this is a baby of course it is
yes
even though leaving you and down look if
your mom was here I've no doubt she'd be
nervous for you but she would be so
excited too so you go but it was this
unexpected bombshell from Scarlett that
has everyone talking one thing
I'm pregnant
[Music]
et spoke with Clare Bowen who plays
scarlet about the shocking pregnancy
reveal Bowen is confident Scarlett will
be a great mom
quote she knows everything happens for a
reason no matter who this baby came from
he or she is a part of her and that is
enough for Scarlett also big news rachel
bilson is heading to music city
the actress posted this photo to
Instagram Thursday announcing she's
joining the Nashville cast
[Music]
you